c'est cette vache resteront bien couché
dans l'herbe au milieu du brouhaha du
centre-ville de toronto
ces chevaux continueront de galoper sur
les berges du fleuve saint laurent à
québec tout comme calgary son taureau
gardera la pause rue georgia à vancouver
et la belle claudia une vache de bronze
trônera encore dans le jardin des
sculptures du musée des beaux-arts de
montréal
mais le scripteur joe fafard lui n'est
plus l'un des artistes canadiens les
plus influentes son époque a rendu l'âme
après plus de 50 ans de carrière pendant
des années soixante dernières années de
5,1 il ya eu ici elle est jeune
l'activité phénoménal dans les arts
visuels joe fafard est né en 1942 à
sainte-marthe un petit village agricole
du sud est de la saskatchewan
dès son enfance ses parents remarquent
et démontre fort intérêt pour les arts
qu'est ce que c'est au début des années
1960 il quitte la saskatchewan pour
étudier les beaux-arts à l'université du
manitoba puits en pennsylvanie dans les
années 1970 joe fafard enseigne à regina
et en californie avant d'entamer sa
carrière d'artiste
il travaille alors principalement la
céramique mais une commande de la
cadillac fairview coopration à toronto
en 1983 changera sa trajectoire
l'entreprise souhaite garnir son terrain
extérieur d'oeuvres d'art joe fafard
crée donc le pâturage cette vache de
bronze se reposant tranquillement dans
l'herbe au coeur du quartier des
affaires
l'impulsion pour ce projet c'est est
venue de ces grands buildings noirs ici
qui s'appelle
en 1985 il ouvre sa propre fonderie à
peine 100 saskatchewan où travaillent
encore aujourd'hui une demi-douzaine
d'employés
ce sont ces vaches chevaux et autres
animaux qu'ils font connaître partout
sur la planète dès les années 1980 mais
il propose aussi des séries de
sculptures inspirées de ses proches et
personnalités qui l'ont marqué ses
oeuvres sont exposées aux quatre coins
du canada mais aussi en france en grande
bretagne et même au japon
monsieur jo on s'assoit au cours de sa
carrière joe fafard a remporté bon
nombre de prix il a été fait officier de
l'ordre du canada en 1981
en plus de recevoir un doctorat
honorifique de l'université de regina en
1989 et de l'université du manitoba en
en 2002 il reçoit l'ordre du mérite de
la saskatchewan et en 2003 le prix
montfort national remis à des
francophones issus de milieux
minoritaires qui excellent dans leur
domaine d'activité qu'est ce que je veux
dire c'est merci toute sa carrière joe
fafard s'est inspiré de ses racines son
enfance sur la ferme sa famille et ses
proches ces oeuvres continueront de
voyager partout sur la planète
ici marie-christine bouillon radio
canada regina